bonjour tout le monde comment allez-vous
aujourd'hui petite vidéo avec jordan ce
n'est pas libre de l'été non on est
redevenu blond mais c'était vraiment le
bazar en plus on se l'est dit par
message c'est une envie c'était un vidéo
à un peu la nostalgie le truc de
voilages en 2019 encore aujourd'hui
c'est pas un concept nouveau vous l'avez
déjà vu sur bigorneaux et coquillages tu
m'expliques concept ouais est-ce que
vous avez l'âme d'un magicien nous oui
oui je commence bien on va chacun notre
tour réalisé des tours de magie
comment trois chacun et l'autre devra
deviner le secret du tour vous aussi
vous avez de votre vie évidemment parce
qu'on vous dira pas le secret du tour
avant d'avoir fait donc vous aussi vous
pouvez deviner chez vous le secret du
tout c'est une phrase de gamme de la
télé réagir je suis agressif j'ai envie
de commencer j'ai trois tours à faire
faut pas se planter et ce qu'on a à
réviser nos travaux pendant 20 minutes
pendant 20 minutes à paraître
jordan j'ai un ballon ok tu connais je
connais j'en ai déjà eu et c'est
beaucoup je le fasse quand même c'est
tout c'est le sauve accessoires ah non
je croyais que tu connaissais le tour au
moment où je suis et je connais les
ballons quoi j'aurai mon coeur s'est
arrêté j'ai écris tu connaissais
toujours j'ai failli pleurer est ce que
tu peux me passer ton téléphone très
intrusif mais pourquoi pas je vais
mettre ton téléphone
dans ce bal on arrête tes conneries tu
puisses tu assures pour ça j'ai besoin
de le gonfler qui motorise j'en vois pas
d'inconvénient c'est un ballon on est
d'accord je vais faire rentrer ton
téléphone à l'intérieur du ballon
ouais c'est comme ça je dois frotter de
manière à ce qu'ils traversent le ballon
d'accord
donc à tanger un deuxième essai bien sûr
c'est beaucoup tu fais exprès de rater
maintenant je vais faire rentrer ton
téléphone dans ce [ __ ] de ballons
c'est en train d'arriver il est rentré
leur entrée la rentrée il est rentré la
vie de ma mère
[Musique]
il est dans le ballon il est dans le
ballon arrête la jda sûr tu peux devait
inspecter bah évidemment venu on peut
prendre un seul fil depuis le ballon on
regarde la marche c'est pour te montrer
qu'il est de n'en rien d'un petit fils
un petit celle fait qu'est-ce que je
dois chan yan tu dois réfléchir et me
dire comment j'ai fait pour faire
rentrer ton téléphone dans ce bal alors
déjà je peux être honnête il ya aucun
souci jordan le téléphone n'est pas dans
le ballon je vois pas de quoi tu parles
il est pas dedans comment çà et là
dedans il est enrobé mais il est même
pas enlever pleinement tu veux d'alger
ema l'enrobé en plus de ne pas l'avoir
fait rentrer plus que j'essaie de jordan
oui bravo tu vas trouver le second
mi-temps mais ce n'était pas l'intention
était vraiment là lé gars c'est un tuto
fait par un mec de 12 ans sur youtube et
je trouvais ça sympa
la route est connoté map reste un dock
magicien une note sur 20 on va partir
sur un petit maigre 12
ça fait mal ça fait un peu mieux mais je
conçois trickett et à ma place là dans
une minute et a besoin d'un ballon j'ai
pas forcément besoin d'un bon pas besoin
de taper de magicien j'ai pas forcément
votre tapis magicien ce que je leur
besoin cependant c'est beaucoup de
machines
ok tu vas faire rentrer mon téléphone
dans un ballon ce serait incroyable
vous serez à tours de magie pour le
projet ici une boîte d'allumettes je
vous la montre siegen tu veux
vérification truc et je peux je peux
craquer une allumette qui observe une
réaction particulière quelque chose de
non magique rien de magique
rien de magique rien de magique pardon
rien de magique pointe pour l'instant
j'ouvre cette bouteille
tu vas te dira et vas-y sous développés
sont rien déjà c'est simple bien jouer
c'est beau jeu mais tu sais tu allumes
est à l'intérieur de la bouteille comme
je pourrais le faire avec n'importe quel
objet que j'introduis dans une bouteille
s'attachera également sa mort je mets
cette année met à l'intérieur
elle flotte qu'est ce qui se passe je
vais pas trouvé ça vraiment mal à penser
que je peux la manipuler cette année met
par exemple à faire bouger avec la
pensée me dis pas que tonton ou gros
ouais c'est juste pour faire bouger la
lumière et non mais bon c'est pas sais
pas si ça
[Musique]
la fin décembre
et c'est bien le cas avec la simple
force de la pensée fiable lucas est mec
je crois que tu m'a [ __ ] perspective
j'ai pas le droit
la lld s'enlacer volontaire de tapas
c'est moi qui ai laissé un peu de pluie
de hockey ma pensée bien sûr je t'en
prie je peux ouvrir tu fais ce que tu
veux si tu crois que c'est une histoire
de pression non en tant qu'attaquant je
te mets au défi pourquoi y'a plus rien
plus le film a tenté en train de dire
que j refermer la bouteille genre et
qu'il y avait un fils potable
ouah c'est très fort comme comme analyse
mais ce n'est pas ça c'est pas ça non
mais je crois que tu as gagné en vrai là
je vais pas débattre dix minutes ce
serait de la triche
jordan je dois t'avouer quelque chose
dis moi tout tu as été vraiment bons
bien meilleur que moi merci beaucoup
et en plus de ça la com ça
instinctivement j'ai pas trouvé moi
j'aurais dit qu'il ya un fil en gros
balle à vous le verrez pas parce que du
coup je vais l'expliqué très simplement
avec l'éducation de pression l'allumette
en fait elle entourée d'un petit point
un petit trombone donc ça ça donne un
poids et quand on appuie sur la
bouteille
donc c'est ce que j'avais dit [ __ ] ça
me rend malade
mais vous êtes des malades je les dirai
plaît si tu crois que c'est une histoire
de pression non tu m'as brain maintenant
tu as gagné tu m'as brain oui tu m'as
brignemont
j'ai trouvé à la première donc c'était
bien juste appuyé ça change la pression
c'était juste tu m'as trop bien brain
parce qu'en fait j'avais trouvé et je me
suis dit [ __ ] mais en fait non c'est
pas ça
arrêtez tout est parti je suis parti
dans le fil dans la théorie de crise
autour du film et parce qu'il ya
vraiment une bonne un pro je dors pas
vraiment été bon mais chelsea
franchement c'est un 18 sur me voir
ouais franchement dit c'est un tour qui
est crabes les mecs tu as été genre
franchement bravo
robben dans ce tour nous avons un
élastique une paire de ciseaux une corde
ce sont les trois seuls éléments de ton
tour de magie les trois sur les éléments
de mon tour de me respecter les éléments
tu peux totalement inspecté les éléments
un par un il n'y a aucun problème
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce type de scotch pas aussi
nous un détail peut-être un marqueur
mais joe jordan
tu vas devoir ma tâche est solidement
les mains chaque tour de poignet
qu'elles soient liées au quai en fête
excellent c'est bon je dois bien tu veux
vérifier genre on état grave les choeurs
voit bien aussi je sais vraiment reliés
jordan je vais faire passer cette
élastique
dans ce film a beau je trouve ça fort
pour ça tu vas me laisser me retourne et
10 secondes
ça c'est un peu suspect s'est alors
c'est un peu galère mais c'est normal
donc se sont un peu égal à djibouti
c'est le principe d'un taux seger et g10
10 secondes tu me laisses 10 secondes
hockey et me regarde pas dans le reflet
du piano sinon t'es un gros tricheurs je
regarde la cave vraiment je regarde pas
le regard là qu'à me regarde pas le
piano il ya pas de soucis de façon je
sais que t'es pas un gros tricheurs mais
on sait jamais ok comment j'ai fait
alors déjà bravo comment j'ai fait pour
mettre l'élastique au milieu je peux
tester des trucs c'est ce que tu veux
c'est malin journée
[Musique]
je pense que tu as fait ça mais dans le
sens inverse
alors écoute moi c'est le statu quo tu
viens de résoudre un casse tête que moi
même je ne savais pas et fait jordan
c'était pas ça c'était pas ça j'ai caché
le 12e élastique dans mon slip et il
était caché ce moment il était caché
sous ma roue on a tous technique de mcd
a trouvé une technique qui aime bien que
celle que j'ai suivi tu as trouvé de
meilleur chute que la chute que j'avais
je sais pas quoi dire mais mais comment
figure déjà dans un premier temps mais
en fait je sais pas te refais toi
j'étais passé là et là je me suis dit
bah ya un petit trou donc forcément
pressés qui si toi donc en fait il ya
une version du tour qui est mieux mais
la bonne nouvelle c'est que tu as quand
même pas trop vu ce que j'ai trouvé le
secret c'est tellement injuste ce qui
t'arrive
c'est pas grave je te mets dix huit 18
mois parce que j'ai aimés comme tt
serein avec ton tour j'ai bien aimé
cette attitude franchement j'étais en
asie solennellement bravo mais gros chez
ça me rend malade
bah désolé mais le gars est vraiment
faible at a fait comme ça pas du tout
mais j'avais un deuxième élastique parce
que je suis un escroc ouais mais les
deux matches et c'est à toi pouvait
faire ton deuxième tour je me retrouve
[Musique]
ça me semble qu'à un tour à me faire ça
très bien du g12 de ce type je m'entends
tu vas mettre une main dans sa poche
aucun lien avec ce qui va se passer pour
la suite
ok ok j'ai deux élastiques aux
solidement accroché avec se doit qui
fait charnière entre les deux dans ma
poche il y un trombone lucas est ce que
tu crois en la téléportation tu peux
dire non tu peux te sentir à l'aise avec
ta réponse non est ce que je peux me
permettre de remettre en question de
remettre mes croyances sur la brouille
est tout à fait je vais inviter lucas a
inséré le petit trombone sur le premier
étage voilà tu l'as bien accroché là est
ce que tu penses que je peux c'est fait
exprès je te leur mais s'il te plaît oui
lucas oui je vais faire passer tout
simplement j'en ai marre je vais
repasser seront bonnes ici ok tu
m'envoies un petit peu un petit mot
magique un petit truc à plait-il wa
talent heureusement que t'as pas
inverser les deux lignes dans le
mouvement parce que sinon c'était un peu
simple comme thor et si je te disais que
il peut passer à celle en dessous
[Musique]
c'est fini à priori oui franchement
bravo
j'apprécie le fait d'avoir voulu tenter
un tour aux gens c'est méga technique
genre là vraiment ces jeux je vois ce
que célia regagne avait déjà fait un
jour il m'avait pas dit comment ça
marche et j'ai franchement j'avais été
hyper scotch et gentes des latics ont
comme sahélienne manille pour switcher
entre deux lignes tu vois est en fait le
trombone ne bouge jamais de ligne tu
changes juste les lignes de place je
sais que tu t'es entraîné que genre
trois minutes avant qu'on tourne donc
apple
lucas c'est exactement ça je ris à
utiliser sept bases à bascule en bas
c'est exactement ça va franchement
qu'ils méritaient j'ai envie de te
mettre 1 12 ça va donc sur le lan chile
pour le bal au bate a tout foiré où
c'est vrai je reviens j'accepte mon 12
cents us à me remettre en question
jacques songy acceptons tous ces bons du
coup il ya un partout tout va jouer sur
les derniers trous à jouer sur les deux
derniers tours voici mes éléments un
petit tas de mouchoirs un épouvantail
alors non un éventail des montagnes
c'est ce que j'ai dit un verre d'eau et
de l'eau infuser ce que j'avais que ça
je me fais un verre
alors suivi non je regarde hockey genre
bam
ouais ici j'ai mon paquet de mouchoirs
je vais faire une petite boule que je
vais 30 et ensuite dans le verre d'eau
[Musique]
on va la laisser un peu reposé normal
elle infuse avec le reste mais la fusée
un peu c'est pas obligée soit de
l'office d'accord car n'y a pas un qui
soit de loin fusée merci pour la
précision
maintenant que ça c'est fait j'ai une
boule oui je ne suis pas vraiment une
boule met d'accord j'ai une patate c'est
pas ta jordan va se transformer en une
pluie de confettis
tu me crois ou pas c'est complètement 1
pouces en dalle c'est simple je vais
partir là et je vais
[Musique]
bah
faire une fuite confettis
t'as kiffé temps mais j'ai adoré situe
peut inspecter nos chefs n'ont jamais
parce que je veux rien inspecté je suis
content là je suis conquis par ce que
jacques château serait sympa non
tapocher mouiller là non ok tu veux
tchèque
ouais de fou tchèque n'est justement un
chef
ouais tout va bien et d'autres poches
notre poche
ok ok ok fort bravo franchement bravo je
sais même pas quoi dire selon moi le
secret de ce tour c'est que du coup bah
tu avais déjà des confettis préparé
quelques parts à tremper ta boule tu la
sortie je sais pas où tu l'as mis et
c'est ça qui me je sais pas où aller
franchement fort sache que tu as trouvé
la mécanique du tour
la boule mais fait actuellement très mal
d'accord elle est sous mon pied droit
frère je la platine depuis maintenant
cinq minutes
j'ai extrêmement depuis le début j'avais
une boule rempli le confetti ici ag je
laisse witch est gelée switcher comme ça
avant de te faire ça ok aux biens sauf
qu'ensuite je l'avais la bouée mouillée
et là je sèche et plus comment il fait
le même coup l'histoire assez donc
j'écris la boule mais j'ai fait tiens
l'éventail j'ai mis dans la poche
et là tu m'as dit je peux tu possèdes
alors là et là j'ai fait ou psy ops est
allé dans la poche la boule et donc
j'étais d'abord fait de checker celle là
et quand j'ai vite aller aller vers
l'autre jeux des sorties jeux des
lâchers partir discrètement je t'ai dit
jack et quand je suis revenu j'ai marché
du compact mais alors la alors là j'ai
tout donné et ta poche n'était même pas
mouillé je me suis dit vas y c'est de la
pure chatte je vais pas y aller par
quatre chemins je vais être complètement
honnête je te mets un fin sur 20 j'ai
dit que personne n'était parfait tu peux
jouer quelque chose de victoire du oui
tant mieux
c'est bye bye lucas oui est ce que tu
crois la transmission de pensée je t'ai
posé la question tout à l'heure pour la
téléportation tu avais l'air de pas trop
croire un téléthon j'y crois pas trop
mais je crois au mentalisme et aux gens
très fort pour me manger le cerveau y
compris des gens qui ont des cheveux
blonds et georges début je trouve la
tour de magie et j'arrive à me mettre
sur une fausse piste très précis comme
très précis s'apprécie on va tester
quelque chose une expérience aujourd'hui
je vais est invité à écrire le mot de
ton choix
ah ça situe le réussit ça va me rendre
dingue attend une petite seconde
tu crois en la mémoire de l'objet tu me
dis un truc de charlatans frère justin
vernon mais je crois toi trouve moi
juste un objet ici qui te tient à coeur
et qui pourrait nous relier tous les je
dois noter là dessus non non non juste
un objet qu'on va poser ici qui va nous
permettre de faire le lien pour notre
pensée ok je te ramène sa one week
layton j'ai pensé qu'à ça le mec c'est
beau c'est mieux c'est beau parce que ça
nous relier san re lire la bible sur
youtube etc
on va le positionner juste ici il tient
droit
j'ai l'impression il va tomber 100% sur
sa sale tour de magie qu'en fait il fait
tomber les objets que je ramène par la
porterez voici l histoire de pression
avec une allumette qu'avant d'être là
lucas je t'invite et a marqué le mot de
ton choix parmi tous les moulins en
français et non comme un les verbes
irréguliers des verbes tout ce que dieu
j'ai le droit à l'argent tous les maux
non vraiment le plus important c'est que
tu regardes pas non je ne regarde pas
plus important c'est qu'on se connaît
tous
[Musique]
c'est ok est ce que tu peux disposer
dans ma main de façon à ce que
évidemment je ne vois pas bien sûr on
est bien d'accord qu'à aucun moment je
peux voir ce qui a marqué dessus
non en aucun cas lucas je vais demander
maintenant de regarder son objet et
qu'on va se connecter tous les deux je
sais comment d'affaires tu sais comment
j'ai fait avec la disposition des objets
de ton côté de la table tu veux sur
l'app store
peut-être ok on va se connecter tous les
deux l'objet ton mot dans cinq lettres
oui jordan ladd a mis le mot au dessus
d'un téléphone comme c'est écrit à
l'envers du coup tu étais là pourquoi
pourquoi pour qu'est ce qu'il a dit est
à repérer cette surface cette affaire au
bâton et a voulu me wade en son genre
non c'est pas une histoire de reflets
pour ensuite aller dans ce reflet là qui
est beaucoup plus claire
olala ça c'est ton tour final oui je te
suis fier d'eux sous charles da je suis
désolé vive il était cool quand même pas
comment te noter c'est que c'est
compliqué je vais m 1,14
je te mets 14 parce que j'ai grillé
instante mais a su improviser et trouver
ton scénario genre où il faut se placer
autour de l'objet et regarder dans le
reflet qui avait dans l'objet tu as su
placer lazare de ton côté infos qu'on
veut c'est foiré à 1000% mais l'impro
l'impro sahel était incroyable danone
annonce ce que les gens veulent comme
saint piat et gagner il faut une guenon
bas y en a deux égalité je crois qu'on a
tous les deux de vinay deux tours de
l'autre sur les 3 c'est un plaisir
vraiment partagé en fait le truc de le
faire face à face te mets dans un état
il y avait un vrai challenge franchement
fait le chez vous toptent pas en fait la
part d'improvisation
c'est ça qui m'a tuer de rire genre
l'aproca hutois sur la lui met sur la
trace de tours en feu c'est tellement
drôle le tu vois le gars qui est
inquiétant ce qui pioche dans ses
ressources tu as il en peut plus il est
au bout il sait que ça a raté mais donne
tout genre ça a pas rater c'est
incroyable non mais merci d'être passé
merci à toi va passer à voir la chaîne
de jordan bien évidemment temps c'est
cool ça c'est lanthimos et puis qu'est
ce qu'on se dit on se dit
[Musique]